[Musica]
l'uomo che emozione buongiorno
buongiorno a tutti mi chiamo bernardo e
oggi vi racconterò la mia storia che
fondamentalmente parla di tre momenti in
cui il primo in cui ero molto sicuro di
me sicuro di quello che volevo fare poi
un momento in cui ho vissuto una
sensazione molto forte in cui mi sono
sentito uno sfigato e poi uno ha un
terzo momento in cui le persone hanno
cominciato a vedere in tutto ciò che
facevo dei valori in cui metteva in
campo giorno per giorno
questa la mia prima slide questa frase
me l'ha detta un amministratore delegato
di un'importante azienda che costruisce
biciclette e quando mi ha chiesto di
fare una presentazione un discorso la
sua alla sua rete vendita che in quel
momento era un pochino poco motivata e
l'omessa qui perché è quello che è
successo anche a me più volte nella mia
vita che qualcuno mi abbia aiutato a da
nomi un calcio nel sedere
io comincio cosi da piccolissimo come
potete vedere mio padre per fortuna non
ha fatto il fotografo perché altrimenti
saremmo morti di fame tutti in famiglia
e ha tagliato perfettamente a metà però
mio padre era un pilota militare e ha
alimentato una mia grandissima passione
che è stata la passione per la velocità
lui la esprimeva con il volo e io vedevo
nel volo la veloce l'emozione della
velocità sono stato anche un per modo di
dire un po un bambino prodigio in quanto
a nove mesi non ho cominciato a
camminare ma ho cominciato correndo nel
corridoio di casa
questa mia
attività è stata presa con estrema
entusiasmo la mia madre che si è
spaventata ha strillato io mi sono
bloccato mi sono seduto e da dall'essere
un leggero bambino prodigio sono
rientrato un bel un bambino in leggero
ritardo in quanto poi ho cominciato a
camminare tre quattro mesi dopo tutti
gli altri però la questa è una foto di
quando io rubavo il casco mio padre per
giocare in giardino e immaginare il volo
e tutto quello che facevo con tutto
quello che di poter poi era relativo al
volo alla velocità alle emozioni che le
velocità mi dava e io ero sicuro di
quello che volevo fare io volevo vivere
quella emozione e quelle fin da ragazzo
ho fu costruito la mia vita nella mia
vita c'era questa immagine.il essere un
pilota militare
tanto che a 18 anni decido di fare un
corso di volo che mi porta per riuscire
a prendere il brevetto è quello che
viene chiamato ppl per poter diventa per
avere maggior non crediti per poter
entrare in aeronautica e perciò
facilitare po il mio percorso
lì e all'interno io vivevo in questo
ambiente mio padre e i suoi colleghi che
parlavano di volo fondamentalmente casa
mia sembrava di stare nel set di top gun
mi mancava tom cruise che dormisse nella
camera di fianco più o meno era tutto
uguale gente che gesticolava con le mani
o faccio così faccio con la gara è stato
tutto molto coreografico faccio questo
corso di volo e cosa succede durante una
missione solista
ho un un'avaria subito dopo il decollo
più o meno un 150 metri di quota
l'aereo precipita e si distrugge si
disintegra il suolo io non mi ricordo
niente nel senso che io ho fatto qualche
giorno di coma conseguenza di un trauma
cranico estremamente importante e quando
mi sono svegliato mi è sembrato di
essere catapultato nella vita di
un'altra persona come se fossi in stessi
guardando il film di un'altra persona
perché appunto mi sono svegliato che
dall'ombelico in giù non muovevo più
niente e questo è stato distruttivo
ormai nel senso non mi riconoscevo più è
stato veramente uno shock e quando mi
guardavo io vedevo questo come un piatto
lasciato cadere per terra che si
distrugge mille parti la forma originale
la conosciamo tutti ma lo vediamo lì
fatto a pezzi durante il giorno in
ospedale c'erano amici che vengono a
trovarmi c'erano i miei genitori
io sono sempre stata una persona
particolarmente propositiva
particolarmente positiva soprattutto per
non caricare i miei genitori di
ulteriori angosce
dopo oltre al fatto di avere un figlio
in prognosi riservata in ospedale
il problema era la notte la notte quando
rimaneva solo l'ospedale era
praticamente silenziosissimo e si
potevano sentire i lamenti di chi stava
male qualche tosone i respiratori che
andavano e l'odore del disinfettante
io per cercare di riuscire a staccare da
questo mi mettevo le cuffie e ascoltavo
più volte al giorno italyan rum casusu
ct che è un album di elio e le storie
tese
se mi faceva ridere mi faceva ridere e
spostava la mia attenzione da quell
angoscia che vivevo del non riconoscermi
del non sapere più che cosa sarebbe
stato di me
dell'aver perso l'orientamento sa di
aver perso la mia bussola il mio nord e
è stato veramente difficile ed è stato
un periodo di scelte perché parlando con
i medici un giorno ascoltavo dei medici
parlare dicevano che una nuova ricerca
aveva stabilito che col 19 per cento dei
muscoli delle gambe una persona riuscivo
a camminare e io ho pensato ma non
riesco a recuperare anche quel 19 per
cento
così ho deciso di farmi sottoporre a
un'altra operazione anche se
sconsigliato dalla prima equipe medica
che mi aveva operato e lì dopo la prima
operazione mi anno dopo si sa dopo la
prima sia dopo la seconda operazione mi
hanno ribadito che molto probabilmente
non avrei mai più camminato con cominciò
a fare fisioterapia
devo entrare in un istituto esterno a
fare fisioterapia incontro e il medico
responsabile e questo persona mi
ribadisce il concetto guardia imparare a
usare bene la sedia rotelle perché tu
non tornerei mai più a camminare
fatto sta però che incontrò una
fisioterapista è stata la mia prima
fortuna questa fisioterapista che si
chiama ilva lei mi guarda mi fa
secondo me non so come ma in qualche
modo potresti tornare a camminare e lì
mi ha galvanizzato lille e ho creduto
ciò credo ci abbiamo creduto tutti e due
e ho cominciato a fare tantissimo
fisioterapia tutti i giorni anche due
volte al giorno i primi risultati
arrivavano e mi passò dalla sedia a
rotelle a camminare con dei tutori e con
le stampelle un medico mi guarda mi fa
stampelle no no no nella tua condizione
con quel poco che muove le gambe rischi
solamente di scivolare e farti del male
e questo potrebbero allentarsi o
comunque lesionati ho fatto un'altra
scelta
non l'ho ascoltato
sono andato avanti e ciò creduto
veramente tanto e ho fatto i miei numeri
sono quattro mesi di serie delle rotelle
un anno e mezzo di stampelle 15 anni di
fisioterapia dopo un po però sono
riuscito a tornare a camminare alle
slide è vuota la slide sono io mi vedete
sono qui in piedi che cammino sono stato
bravo
ci ho messo un po di tempo però mancano
ancora sette minuti
vabbè magari vi racconto qualcos'altro
andiamo avanti con qualcos'altro
vi ricordate il 19 per cento di prima
bene io ero riuscito a recuperare
addirittura il 30 per cento
un 10 per cento e spicci in più caspita
sono stato ero devo essere contentissimo
no dalle 19 minimo arrivare al 30 no
perché non guardavo il 30 per cento che
ero riuscito a recuperare io guardavo
quel 70 che mi mancava e che cosa voleva
dire voleva dire che mi sentivo
fondamentalmente inadeguato mi sentivo
sempre in difetto rispetto agli altri
pensavo che le persone mi guardassero
per il mio modo di camminare perché non
camminavo bene e in ogni in maniera
cercavo di nascondere questo mio design
questo mio camminare male in modo da non
essere a disagio in modo da non sentirmi
meno degli altri
e il mio focus è stato lì per tantissimo
tempo per molti anni fino a quando non
provo questo tutor in carbonio di nuova
all'epoca era di nuova concezione lo
provo lo metto su e sento che la mia
vita cambia perché la percezione è molto
molto diversa mi dà molta più stabilità
mi dà molta più sicurezza e con questa
stabilità e questa sicurezza
io torno al mio primo amore e ci torno
subito cioè dopo due minuti che io su
provo a correre e vado cadeau e vado
lungo disteso fantastico
ero la persona più contenta
dell'universo non sto scherzando perché
la sensazione che avevo avuto nonostante
fossi caduto era ottima
si poteva fare
io all'epoca avevo abbandonato la
fisioterapia non perché non mi piacesse
più o perché stessi bene ma perché ho
incontrato la bicicletta e la bicicletta
da ciclismo classico quelle che vedete
che vanno in giro per i colli giro
d'italia per darvi un'idea mi faceva
come la fisioterapia
perciò se ho salutato la mia
fisioterapista e mi dedicavo la bici e
andando in giro in bici vedevo i ragazzi
delle squadre di triathlon che si
allenavano e nella mia mente già da
qualche anno c'era il concetto che il
triathlon rappresentasse la normalità
perché nel triathlon vedevo il modo che
all'uomo di muoversi nello spazio
nuotando perciò in un fluido camminando
correndo e con uno strumento creato da
sel
perciò per me il triathlon equivale alla
normalità e quando provo questi tutori e
sento che posso correre
la prima cosa che faccio vado a
iscrivermi una squadra di triathlon e
vado a iscrivermi ad un corso di corsa
che non è un bel gioco di parole ma vado
da una società di atletica che
organizzava dei corsi per insegnare le
persone correre io era 16 anni che non
correvo più è la prima cosa di cui ero
consapevole che non sapevo più correre
perciò vado da loro e cominciò a
imparare come si fa a l'appoggio l'aca
dà la spinta l'alzata e ricomincio piano
piano a correre male piano lentamente ma
ricomincia a correre e per me ogni volta
era un'emozione tanto che questa foto li
dimostra l'amore romantico che provo per
i miei tutori al tramonto e con questi
vado verso quella cosa quella chimera
per me è impossibile che era il
triathlon
mi alleno per un anno e arrivo a fare la
mia prima gara la mia prima gara è stata
estremamente interessante questa è la
foto dell'arrivo soprattutto per una
cosa che per me è stata importantissima
non tanto il fare la gara
che per me rappresentava non solo non
essere più in difetto è arrivare al pari
degli altri ma andare oltre perché tutti
i miei amici tutte le persone che
conoscevo il creato non avrebbero
neanche mai approcciato lontanamente
perché era una cosa troppo difficile per
cui per me era un punto di arrivo oltre
quello che avrei dovuto fare per
sentirmi normale in realtà ho scoperto
ho trovato molto molto altro
ho trovato una squadra che mi ha
aspettato calcolate che io sono arrivato
40 minuti dopo l'ultimo della mia
squadra loro non sono andati a pasta
party sono stati lì di fianco a 100
metri dall'arrivo per aspettarmi e
arrivare correndo con me ed è stata
un'emozione incredibile perché loro
hanno visto i valori che stavo che io
mettevo in campo giornalmente mi andavo
ad allenare alzandomi alle cinque e
mezza della mattina per andare a nuotare
con loro tre volte la settimana per un
anno e gli hanno condivisi e quello è
stato fantastico mi sono sentito di
nuovo dentro con alla società di nuovo
normale pur essendo diverso oggi da
quella foto da quella gara sono passati
sei anni
oggi cosa faccia oggi vado in giro per
l'italia portando avanti un messaggio un
messaggio che riguarda l'inclusione
della disabilità vorrei che le persone
quando guardano un disabile che è
diverso da una persona normale un
invalido è diverso però vorrei che non
lo guardassero per ciò che gli manca ma
per le opportunità che ancora qui sono a
roma sono partito da casa mia
avete un paesino fuori treviso e sono
andato anche quest'anno in bicicletta a
roma per portare questo messaggio lungo
l'italia 754 chilometri e in 10 giorni
in sette giorni e scusate a una media di
107 km al giorno ed è stato fantastico
end sono riuscito andare
un'altra volta oltre
a quello che mi e mi sarei aspettato da
me tutte queste cose le ho fatte perché
sono riuscito negli anni a trasformare i
miei vissuti la mia angoscia prima il
mio sentirmi da solo il mio non avere
più un obiettivo in energia positiva e
propositiva come anzi propulsiva verso
nuovi obiettivi
infatti ho scelto di non usare di
continuare usare le stampelle e sono
uscito tornare a camminare
ho scelto di correre di provare a
tornare a correre
trasformando quel quella sensazione di
essere meno in qualcosa in energia per
cercare di qualcos'altro qualcosa che mi
desse soddisfazione e e allora mi sono
dato il diritto di rincorrere i miei
sogni che era il sogno di correre
perciò sono ritornato a rincorrere la
corsa soprattutto facendo cosa dandomi
la possibilità di sbagliare che è stata
fondamentale nella mia vita cioè non
fermarmi agli errori non aver paura
dell'errore perché io era il giudice
peggiore di me stesso ero quello che si
faceva fermare prima ancora di partire è
un'altra cosa importante è scegliere io
ogni giorno scelgo io ho una caviglia in
artrosi che è particolarmente dolorosa e
ogni mattina quando la metto giù metto i
piedi giù dal letto mi fa male ma non
permettono al n è la mia disabilità di
decidere qual è la mia vita
so che fa infatti dieci quindici passi
la smetterà di farmi male perché si
abitua perché probabilmente il mio
cervello si abitua e ogni mattina mi
alzo sento male e scelgo di camminare di
non stare a letto di non trovare qualche
altre alternative perché
come dice l nella sua poesia invictus
io sono il padrone del mio destino
io sono il capitano della mia anima
io ho scelto e voi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]